est-ce que parmi vous il ya des élèves
qui parlent déjà un peu à la légère
20 mes parents ils ne parlent souvent il
dans l'océan pensé me parle un peu en
rab et du coût d'un et je comprends à 10
ans et denis phare a fait sa première
rentrée au collège comme 37 autres
élèves de 6e
elle intègre une classe bilangue de
l'anglais mais aussi de l'arabe
littéraire parler dans les livres ou à
la télé est différent de tous les
dialectes propres à chaque pays
c'est un choix que je voulais faire et
que mes parents aussi
on dit que ça serait bien de savoir par
les écrits romans parce qu'aussi le dise
à mieux qu'ils viennent du liban et us à
vous aussi de parler l'arabe littéraire
est en fait moi je pratique que la cour
dont ce serait bien si pratique elle a
rappelé le but proposer l'arabe à
besançon à des enfants d'origine
maghrébine ou non et qui pour certains
le parle couramment la maison un moyen
aussi d'encadrer l'apprentissage de
cette langue
loin des confusions et des préjugés dont
elle est parfois victime la rave avec
l'école est proposé dans un cadre
républicain et laïc c'est justement ça
c'est une idée de base
l'arabe est proposé comme une langue on
importe quelle autre langue et qui n'est
pas
li à une religion et qui n'est pas lié à
un pays
et c'est justement ça l'idée de que sur
lequel je veux travailler avec les
élèves c'est comme mélanger l'arabe avec
les autres disciplines afin de favoriser
la diversité des langues au collège